[Music]
hmm
[Music]
what's up mkbhd here and this is the new
m1
ipad pro
it looks
almost exactly the same as the last one
that's because if the screen's not on it
almost is the same as the last one but
there are a couple things that are new
about this that make it even more of the
ultimate ipad which again
naturally raises the question of like
well what is an ipad anyway and what is
a computer
i'll get to that later so the last ipad
pro wasn't that long ago you can watch
the review from last year but in short
it had an a12 z chip and that was a spec
bump from the previous ipad pro which
had an a12x now of course there were
other small bits and things that made
last year's ipad new but now again in
2021 we have an even more powerful chip
so this ipad pro has apple's m1 inside
now the a12x and the a12z were already
apple designed silicon for the ipad so
while we know m1 is a different breed
since it's also apple designed silicon
it'd be tempting to think maybe that's
not that big of a jump like those chips
were made for the ipad how good could m1
be
that'll be wrong this is a massive
performance leap forward m1 in this new
ipad pro means that now internally this
tablet is basically the same as the m1
macbook air a full-blown computer that
means an 8-core cpu eight core gpu 16
core neural engine and for the first
time apple is just openly telling us how
much ram is in the ipad so that's eight
gigs in the lower storage versions and
16 gigs of ram
in the one terabyte or the new two
terabyte ipad configurations 16 gigs of
ram in an ipad so it turns out
yeah this thing flies again through ipad
os i'm sure it's shocking to you that an
even more powerful even faster chip
continues to crush ipad os in its latest
version but there's a couple other like
specific unique ways i've noticed this
first of all even the heaviest most
graphically demanding apps that i use
are snappy and blazing fast that's
probably also as you'd expect but also
with all this ram and this is a one
terabyte ipad so it has 16 gigs of ram
it really seems like nothing ever needs
to drop from memory it's kind of wild
like we're already used to a bunch of
the most recent apps staying in ram on
the ipad and that's great but here even
the oldest heaviest apps in my
multitasking tray just
pick right up where they left off like
lightroom from hours ago
games streaming apps
it really feels like this ipad's super
power here stuff just happily sits in
ram all day and is always ready to go
but even that doesn't really fully
explain the speed so let me just so so
numbers people we like benchmarks right
they're the easy way to
contextualize the differences in
performance so remember when the a12z
ipad pro last year was already pretty
far ahead of most other tablets on
geekbench for example that was hitting
somewhere around 4500 to 4700 on
multi-core and so was the a12x this m1
ipad hit
6900 points
sometimes breaking 7 000. that's just in
a completely new stratosphere that's
actually higher than the 16-inch macbook
pro
on the longer more detailed antutu
benchmark the a12z was a small bump up
over the a12x so it went from 717 000
to 723 thousand
then m1 ipad pro just casually drops a
score of 1 million 84 000 points so it's
literally 30 to 45
faster than the last ipad pro which was
already faster than pretty much every
other tablet it's like you just don't
see these types of performance increases
year to year
that often
uh so we knew apple silicon was special
but i mean it's just kind of ridiculous
it's actually kind of a struggle to find
the places where a regular user might
find this extra performance here like i
guess that's the point a regular user is
never going to use all of this
performance they'll get an ipad air but
hey this is called the ipad pro for a
reason and so there are actually a few
pro workflows that might be taxing the
current ipads or might benefit from the
extra headroom in the new one
i did a one hour imovie export test the
last ipad pro crushed it in 17 minutes
the m1 ipad did it in 12 minutes flat so
there's another 30 improvement for you
if you're doing a bunch of batch
lightroom imports and exports for
example or just a bunch of heavier
things like that in succession then of
course this new ipad is going to be
great and then all that ram makes the
heavier edits in lumafusion or bigger
projects with a lot more layers in
photoshop that type of stuff more snappy
that's that's the real high-end benefit
here but there are a few other new
things with this ipad pro too aside from
just performance uh it is a little bit
thicker and heavier actually it's it's
barely you might not even notice but
it's uh we're talking half a millimeter
thicker and 50 grams but it was enough
for me to notice so i'm mentioning it to
you uh and it's actually to accommodate
the new m1 stuff the new display which
i'll get to but also a little bit of a
bigger battery physically speaking in
this bigger one so
would you look at that apple making a
product slightly thicker for a slightly
bigger battery
nice the cellular option which i'm
holding is also now 5g which is pretty
sweet so now in addition to the antenna
bands the cellular ipad now has this
little plastic cutout at the bottom next
to the speakers just like the 5g iphones
have on the sides
and that usb-c port at the bottom now
that there's an m1 chip inside is now a
thunderbolt port with usb 4 speeds up to
40 gigabits per second throughput which
is
massive so if you want to plug in an
ethernet dongle here you can get 10
gigabit ethernet which
hey if your setup involves plugging your
ipad and ethernet more power to you but
also that's a huge win for faster file
transfers again if you're importing like
a ton of photos straight from the camera
through a cable or even videos it's
enough bandwidth to now really make a
difference you can also plug straight
into the pro display xdr and drive it at
full resolution 6k
again not sure whose setup that is but
more power to you but maybe the most
interesting unexpected change to this
new ipad is now actually the
front-facing camera so no they didn't
move it to the middle at the top where
it should be but they did add
an ultra wide camera now listen i'm
never gonna advocate for taking photos
on the ipad it's just it's just not
gonna happen but something i do on the
ipad pretty often is video calls video
chats face times and this new camera
setup with a 122 degree field of view is
great for that so basically when you
open the camera app for a selfie you'll
see the normal view but when you zoom
out you'll see a whole lot more of the
scene with that ultra wide now it's
heavily distorted near the edges even
with distortion correction turned on in
settings
not sure that is actually correcting
anything but hey an ultrawide camera is
really useful despite not solving the
problem of being in the wrong place
now when you're in a supported app
there's a new feature called center
stage that kicks in and does a pretty
good job of basically following a face
around that ultra wide frame so it zooms
in a bit and focuses on the face and
keeps it kind of near the middle and if
more than one face gets into the frame
it also tries to stay wide enough to
keep them both and follow both of them
overall it's pretty simple just a sort
of a neat touch but it works pretty
smoothly most of the time and i found it
a nice addition that just makes a lot of
sense on the ipad also if you ever want
to turn this off you can jump into the
settings app pick the app that you want
to turn it off in and then within the
settings you'll see a center stage
checkbox
so there's no other settings or
adjusting it you can just turn it on or
off so if you want to keep it on in
facetime but turn it off in zoom then
you can make that happen if you're
thinking this might also finally let
face id work for more angles
it doesn't it's it's literally just the
camera so the dot projector and infrared
stuff is all working the same way it
normally does just the camera's wider
okay there's one last feature that
is new on this ipad pro and really does
make a pretty big difference and that is
this screen this new screen here so on
the bigger one
just the bigger one the bigger 12.9 inch
ipad pro you've got a new
liquid
retina xdr display it's pretty sweet but
this smaller 11 inch ipad pro basically
has the same screen as last year but
this new screen is awesome mainly it
just it gets way brighter which is
immediately noticeable way more visible
if you're near a window or in bright
environment and it's a mini led display
with 2500 local dimming zones made up of
10 000 mini leds all to say you're going
to get a couple things brighter
highlights up to 1600 nits for peak
brightness full hdr support and better
contrast so you're at a million to one
contrast ratio now
to me honestly it looks just about as
good as oled i mean the thing about so
much of the content you watch on the
ipad is you almost always have those
black bars because of the aspect ratio
and those look way closer to black now
with the black bezels plus there's all
this local contrast and specular
highlights just look awesome so now any
shows or videos you want to watch in hdr
look that much more impressive and a
full hdr creation workflow is sort of
unlocked now from beginning to end so if
you want to shoot and edit and export
and upload hdr videos or photos you can
do all of that from this ipad so now
remember when i was saying the you know
the iphone 12 started shooting dolby
vision hdr video but it turns out there
wasn't that many places to actually view
it
well here's one more great place to view
it on the
larger
new m1 ipad pro now the question that
i'm sure is on plenty of minds like it
was on mine when i saw the announcement
why no mini led on the smaller m1 ipad
pro
i'm i'm thinking it's a cost thing this
is just me speculating
you know it is more expensive oled is
also more expensive but not quite as
bright so this is a great tech to see in
the ipad
but it's kind of a shame because i
really like this smaller ipad pro that's
the one i personally use from back in
2018 actually
so because this new one doesn't have
this mini led display it's yet another
performance bump that i don't need so i
feel like i'm not going to upgrade i'm
gonna keep using my two generation old
11 inch ipad pro but yeah this one
is nice everything else though about
this m1 ipad pro is pretty much exactly
the same as last year's which is to say
really really really good so the quad
speakers are still super loud and sound
great the microphones are still awesome
the body is still all metal same design
and the dual cameras plus lidar are
still here on the back and still great
for a tablet plus actually the m1 chip
now allows for smart hdr3 from the rear
cameras for all you ipad photographers
out there please don't
uh but then again ipad os
is still
ipad os which to me really gets me
thinking that
the ipad os 15 update that's coming up
has got to be a pretty significant
change
to what we have now in ipad os 14.5 like
it's got to be right but there's been
some rumors floating around now about
some pretty big home screen changes
widgets being able to drop anywhere on
any home screen and maybe some more
significant multitasking improvements on
the ipad i might keep my eye out at wwdc
for something like that but yeah i mean
other than that it's again it's it's
another ipad pro doing the same stuff
even faster so if you had some some
bottleneck issues if you had those heavy
pro workflows then you'll really notice
the difference between m1 ipad pro and
the already fast a12z ipad pro but yeah
it's getting kind of ridiculous at this
point alright a couple other
miscellaneous things that didn't quite
fit into the full review there is a new
magic keyboard for the ipad pro people
were wondering about
slightly different uh but it's
functionally exactly the same really is
just adjusted slightly for the half a
millimeter of extra thickness for the
ipad so you can still totally use the
old magic keyboard i tried works perfect
it just might feel a little bit snug
when it's closed that's all no biggie
and the battery life even though a bunch
of variables have changed still feels
about the same maybe a little bit worse
if anything because you gotta factor in
so now if your battery life is here you
add a more powerful m1 chip you add 16
gigs of ram that tons of apps are
staying in you add a mini led display
that's much brighter but also a larger
battery capacity so we've ended up about
the same rating so at the end of the day
it's rated for the same 10 hours as the
last one i feel like the magic of the m1
is really giving me great standby time
but i was able to run through the
battery a little faster at full
brightness with high intensity stuff
going on especially when connected to
the magic keyboard not a huge surprise
this m1 ipad pro is the ultimate spec
bump because again fundamentally it's
just crushing the same things that any
previous ipad pro could do
just even faster with a better screen
and that's going to be great for a lot
of people but i'm just i feel like i'm
just impatient for like a better use of
all this power
if that makes sense like it feels like
i'm
like like upgrading to a ferrari but
sitting in city traffic all day you know
what i mean or like
strapping rockets to your car when what
you really wanted was a pickup truck
i don't know if i'm making any sense
right now my point is if it's a computer
you're after
uh the m1 macbook air is the same
computer
but uh it's cheaper it's thinner it's
lighter it's better balanced overall as
a computer with the keyboard and the
screen
it's not an ipad you know it's not a
touch screen it doesn't have 5g no
center stage but if it's a tablet you're
after with the touchscreen with 5g with
all the apps with the apple pencil with
the xdr display all this stuff
this is the goat it's the goat of
tablets i'm saying it
it can also
sort of convert partially into a
computer
if you want it to
but as i explored in this video right up
here it isn't really ready to be like a
full-time computer for a lot of people
just quite yet but as a tablet it's the
goat matter of fact here's a theory to
think about is this new ipad
too good
meaning like it feels like
the only thing holding this ipad back is
apple protecting
the max a little bit because honestly
think about it if this ipad got the ios
15 makeover that i want if it got
final cut and it got like a serious
keyboard dock that you just plug into
and it's weighted properly and it
doesn't suck on your lap
i wouldn't have a macbook
honestly i would just use this like
would anyone need a laptop if the
software really made the difference
something to think about i'll uh
entertain that in the comment section
below anyway that's basically it thanks
for watching subscribe
if you haven't already what are you
waiting for
catch you guys
in the next one
peace